（あれれなんで開かねえんだ...）
ガチャーーーン
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです。
見ましたか...これぇ、「ポテトチップス」ではなく、
『ドッキリ用のポテトチップス』です。
結構スゴイ量出るなこれ
ポテトチップスの箱に見えて
中に「バネ」が入っていると、
でこうやって、ふたをして、例えば誰かに渡して、
んん～！ポテトチップスだー！食べる食べる！！
つって開けた瞬間、
（ウ”ア”ァ”ァ”ァ”ァ”ァ”ァ”ン”.........）
出てくると、
いう訳でございます！
これ多分皆さんの想像してるよりはるかに威力強いですぞ...
裏にしてやってみたらもう...どうなる×3
もこんな飛ぶんすよ！
という訳でこんかいは、
やっぱさ、飛ぶもの見たらさ、
飛ばしたくなんじゃん!
という訳でこれを何とか魔改造して、
もっと威力を高くして、
もうわんちゃーん（？）
兵器になるんじゃねかぐらいの威力まで上げようと思います。
作戦その壱
ひとまず一つの筒になるべくたくさんのバネを入れてみましょう。
それがまず最初の条件でしょう。
あれぇ？
スーパーポンポンタイム
というわけでこれを、いかに、うまく利用して
威力の高いポテトチップスマシンを作れるかという話でございます。
ひとまず、これ一つに何個バネが入るんだろう？
一個は普通に入るんですよ。
あーもう一個ぐらいイケるな。
二個目いきます。
おおー
あっ！
もう一個いイケる！
うわヤベェこれ！
うわぁ！あ！あぁ！
もう一個入る！
もう一個入る！×2
何個入るかの手品みたいになっちゃってるわ…w
うぉぁー！４つ入るかぁ！
あ？
まだイケるぞ！
これでラストです！多分。
ア”ァ”ァ”！ヤバイ！腕が！腕が！
ヤバイ！ヤバイ！
ほんとに強いっすこれ
いやもう無理だ。
一回これで蓋閉じましょう。
ヤバイ！キツイキツイキツイ…！
ハァハァハァ…
よし！
うぉぉ！重っ！
はいという訳でこの中に５つ分入っています。
これやばいべ、
多分めちゃくちゃ強いと思うよ。
じゃ、じゃぁ、じゃぁ、飛ばしてみまぁ〜す。
果たしてこれでどれくらいの威力があるのかを、ひとまず検証してみましょう。
開けますよ！
スリー
トゥー
ワン
ガーーシャン
あぁ！
〜♪静かな水の流れる音〜
〜♪コン！(ししおどし)〜
あはぁ、あはぁ……
ｳｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｫ!!!
ｷﾀｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧ!!!!!
あぁ…！
これは燃える…！
これ頑張って底をくりぬいたら
２つ合体させたりできないかな？
２つ合体させたら、さらにたくさん入ると思うんで
何とか底を…
なんとか貫通できれば良いんですけど…
貫通したぁ！↑↑
しゃーーあ
これをくっつけて
さらにたくさんのー
待ってこれたくさん完成させれば良いんじゃね？
スーバーかんかんタイム
これだけあればいいでしょ！
一つの筒に５個までバネが入ったんで
３５本くらいはバネが入る予定です。
さてこいつら組み合わせていきましょう。
これ超入念にしなきゃだな…。
ミスが許されないからな…。
ﾍｪｯﾌﾝ!(くしゃみ)
ﾍｪｯﾌﾝ!(くしゃみ)×2
待ってバネって何個だっけ？
バネ２３個なんで、
5,10,15,20…
これでいいと思います！
４つに多分２３個ギリちょうど入るぐらいなんで、
今からこの中に大量のバネを入れていきます。
ﾌﾍｯﾍｯﾍｯﾍ!!
ん゛ん゛あ゛ぁ゛！！まだ入る！
はぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ！！！
ええええええええええ！？
あー腕がやべぇ！
腕が！
うおー！できた！できた！
できた！×3
できた！×4
できた！×5
ふおおおおお！
できたーーー！×6
怖い怖い怖い…！
はいという訳でこちらが！
…になります！
あんまり触りたくない！
ほんとに威力はマジでヤバイと思うんで、
今回はさっそくこれを使って
ドッキリを仕掛けたいと思います！
では行こう！
まさき)ライフ尽きるまでが…
はじめ)神宣使えばいけるよ、多分。
ま)…うん。
は)多分ね。
は)まさき腹減ってない？
ま)腹減った。
は)ポテチ食う？
は)ポテチ…食べたい？
は)別に普通のなんか、たくさん食べたいかなと思って
は)くっつけただけなんだけど(大嘘)
は)よかったら食べて。
ま)えへっへっへっなぁ〜w
は)ひとまず、たっ、たべ
ま)エヘッ↑ヘッ↑ヘッ↑wwwww
ま)やだ開けたらなんかww
は)ホント違う美味しいからｗ
は)お腹空いてるっしょ？
は)ホントよかったら食べて
ま)えっ、いい？いい？開けるよ？
ぶしゃーーーーー
は)ハッハッハッハッハッハッハッハッハ！！！
おわり
ま)こっわｗｗｗ
は)はっはっはｗｗ
は)はっはっはっは…ｗｗｗｗ